あ
ほねほねザウルス100個分のパーティーせめて10名することができました
あのすごい大変だったよじゃあもう良い奴は俺がたを進めればいいやっぱり頑張った分
でこのこれをネイダール100個使ってマジで最強にカッコイイドラゴン
際まずで最強にカッコいい距離を作ろうと思います
すごい馬ず同氏を当初何からすればいいんだろまずはこちらの音なんか説明書に書いて
あった
ultimate アルティメットゴールデンドラゴン
ブーバーバカにしてるわけじゃないしてまぁちょっと慣れちゃったそれでドラゴンを
つくってみましょう
パーティ数が膨大すぎてやばい観客みんなやばいよなと大
ね思ったほどカッコよくないですねええかっこいいよかっこいいけど結構パスがこんな
にあるとねやっぱこれを見てもそんなにすごくないなって思っちゃいます
たいときでアルティメットゴールデンドラゴンでした
このテープでアルティメットゴール前トラップ可愛い私はその上を行くこいつをベース
にすっげー進化させる気がするんですけどじゃあまずこの状態からいじっちゃうよ
あの自分でいるまだなんですけど
構成されますよなんだってこんなもんから先ほどのアルティメットゴールデンドローも
僕なりにカスタマイズしてみました
でーすアルティメットゴールデンはじめんとの本 gx です
ん
me
結構かっこよくないですかあのー
あああ最高に楽しいレッサーも声ないっちゃ好きなんですよ昔た鯉ブロック系が好きな
んだよ
色々作ってみるかですアルティメットゴールではじめドラゴンズジェクサーここ
ちょっと休憩
ちょっと色々作ってみよう
ですできましたキメラテックぷるーワイバーンですかっこいい
めちゃがってやっぱりこの中バサッとしている感じがすごい好きですってなんか
ドラゴンにはですねその下半身がすごい細いタイプ l んですよ遊戯王という
クリアーイングシンクロドラゴンみたいな感じですね
いやーかっこいい所
ん
me
it でホネホネザールで100個使って様々なものを作ってきたんですけどもこれが
本当にシャイなものすべてのパーツを作って1匹の恐竜を作ることそれが俺の
オリジナルファレホ値段ですだと思ってるんで全部のパーツを使って1匹の間にほね
ザウルスを作ってみようと思いますで割と大事な彼は可能性とバランスがいかにして
うまく恐竜を作る方のちょっと時間がかかります
ん
ズームを全部のパーツを使って完成しました気がテストロイヤー赫赫360部位です
やってる途中で気付いたんですけどパンツが噛み合わな全部のパンツを作ってちゃんと
した興味を作るんですっげー難しかっ
これが僕の中の恐竜の限界ですでもでも安心してくれ
一応全部口的なんでちゃんと骨までザブジェになってはもう
姉ちゃんと1匹の恐竜になってるんだよあ
ten